[MUSIC PLAYING]
What's my most striking
feature?
Is it my Christmas jumper?
Is it my height, or
my ginger hair?
Sadly, my ginger hair was often
the brunt of jokes when
I was younger.
But hopefully, many of you can
see this is rather silly, and
it becomes even more so when
you consider the minute
genetic differences that
give rise to it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So up on the screen
are two hairs.
On the right is a brown
hair from my wife.
On the left is one of my
hairs, a ginger hair.
And when we look down the
microscope, you can't really
see too much of a difference,
except for the obvious one,
which is one is a lot darker
than the other.
Now the difference between these
two hairs is mostly down
to a gene found on chromosome
16 called melanocortin 1
receptor, or MC1R for short.
And this gene controls
the type of pigment
produced in the hair.
Brown hairs like the one on the
right contain a lot of a
dark pigment called eumelanin.
Ginger hairs like mine contain
a lot of a lighter pigment
called pheomelanin.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This here is all 954
bases of MC1R.
And this here is a version of
the gene that gives rise to
ginger hair like mine.
Now the difference between them
might not be immediately
apparent, so I'm going to show
you exactly how these differ.
There, just one single base
change in all 954 is enough to
give me ginger hair.
So there are actually a number
of these MC1R gene variants,
so basically alternate versions
with a single
spelling difference, that can
give rise to ginger hair.
And this isn't confined
to the MC1R gene.
You can find a number of these
single spelling differences
throughout the human genome.
There are about 60 million of
them, and we call them single
nucleotide polymorphisms.
Most of these spelling
differences are invisible,
meaning that they don't change
how we look on the outside.
But at the genetic level, they
still differentiate one person
from another.
But even when they do give rise
to something like ginger
hair, doesn't it seem rather
stupid to pick on someone for
essentially one base pair
difference out of the three
billion that make
up our genome?
[MUSIC PLAYING]